[Music]
you're trying to arm like this actually
an extension you can't do that you're do
not don't have it pushing stop pushing
now straight that's a pushy intention
you you're going like this you know push
and then you go like see how it shut up
you know pushing attention stop moving
my arm like this isn't she should only
go there everything so that's where the
rotation happens now you can't confuse
this with a demon dog yet you stopped
pushing it so what's happening is you
want to take the camel but you don't
take a Kimmy
you receive Academy okay so when you go
like time for echidna you stop the
intention is to get it and then you go
get ready to go backwards okay but
that's a very low level so you have a
pushing intention you did it again
anytime you do it again - Chris so this
is what I have DC he's he's doing that
because all his arm is doing is this you
see that so it's travelling around the
circumference of a circle do you see
that right can you see it now if so my
arm is a vector that's kind of do the
circle so why should it do anything but
just get stuck here okay
do you understand but when you guys go
like Tom Ford cami so he's here and he's
pushing you should just say that if you
can picture a ball right right and all
the ball is doing is turning and the
vectors coming through it's going to hit
the circumference here I had a right
angle so it's a conflict do you
understand okay so I need to find a way
of spinning his arm I do that a couple
ways so one way is that I'm not turning
like this when I get here I'm actually
pushing his arm so he comes in another
way I do it is I take my elbow and when
I can't get that you see he's strong
right there I lift it up so it's not a
ball that's turning like this it's a
ball that's turning both ways
then my foot maneuvers make up the rest
so if I feel it oh it's really strong
here then look I take off the energy so
he's pushy
let's pushing me back as he's pushing me
back I'm controlling the spot the two
spirals of my arms can't be independent
they work together so easy me is he gets
in that Kazushi here I hit that final
destination base hit the final this all
at the same time
[Music]